ahsoka tano was supposed to be obi-wan
kenobi's padawan but yoda assigned her
to anakin skywalker instead and it
doesn't get any less complicated from
there keep watching for all the ins and
outs of ahsoka and obi-wan's
relationship
one of the most interesting aspects of
obi-wan and ahsoka's relationship is the
fact that he's basically her jedi
grandfather jedi are trained one-on-one
passing their teachings from master to
student following specific generational
lines of jedi that ahsoka is proud to
belong to this jedi legacy begins
decades before the films when jedi grand
master yoda decides to train a young boy
named dooku that boy grows up to train
qui-gon jinn the jedi master who
discovers a small child named anakin
skywalker on the desert planet tatooine
but because jyn is killed by darth maul
before he can train the boy his former
padawan obi-wan kenobi takes anakin on
as his apprentice in his stead so when
obi-wan and anakin fight count dooku in
attack of the clones they are in a sense
fighting family but jedi aren't meant to
form attachments or know their
biological relatives as a result the
relationships between master and
apprentice are often the closest thing
they have to parental bonds so whenever
ahsoka is instructed in ways of the
force she is hearing the echoes of all
the jedi who came before her whether
she's hearing them directly from obi-wan
or through anakin
strangely enough ahsoka was originally
meant to be obi-wan's second padawan not
anakin's first obi-wan puts in a request
for a new apprentice from the planet
christofis shortly before the beginning
of the 2008 animated film star wars the
clone wars when ahsoka arrives obi-wan
introduces himself as her new master
before ahsoka corrects him and announces
that she's actually been assigned to
anakin i've got a bad feeling about this
though obi-wan seems to be surprised in
the moment a later scene between obi-wan
and yoda seems to indicate that this has
been the duo's plan all along that said
it is still interesting to wonder what
the relationship as master and
apprentice would have been like obi-wan
has plenty of opportunities to train and
mentor the young jedi throughout the
clone wars as he anakin and ahsoka
travel and fight together more often
than not
obi-wan kenobi mentors ahsoka tano in
many different ways but one of the most
compelling is his position as her
commanding officer during the clone wars
the jedi take on official military ranks
in the grand army of the republic that
directly correspond to the ranks within
the jedi order obi-wan kenobi becomes
the high jedi general in charge of the
seventh sky core alongside clone marshal
commander cc2224
aka cody anakin's clone legion the
famous 501st is one of the many legions
under the seventh sky core and as such
is under the overarching command of
obi-wan though the two are no longer
master and apprentice obi-wan is still
anakin's commanding officer which makes
obi-wan responsible for ahsoka as well
star wars the clone wars features a
large cast of characters however anakin
skywalker obi-wan kenobi and hisoka
tunnel become the closest thing the
series has to main characters the three
work closely together throughout the war
and any story that features one of them
almost always features the other two as
well
the clone wars explores the galaxy's
journey between the events of star wars
episode 2 attack of the clones and those
of star wars episode 3 revenge of the
sith ahsoka is the most important new
character the show introduces so it's
only natural that she joined anakin and
obi-wan as the show's lead characters
the movie that kicks off their story
begins with their first meeting and then
the last story of the series ending
season begins their final encounter then
order 66 changes everything
though this might seem like an
unorthodox way to put it obi-wan
basically helps anakin raise ahsoka over
the course of the war the three of them
work together on many different missions
this is a time of tremendous growth for
ahsoka which obi-wan is almost entirely
present for and so obi-wan helps guide
anakin as he trains ahsoka and learns
how to be a teacher likewise ahsoka
often looks to obi-wan for guidance as
she learns to navigate the universe at
large and her master's unique tendencies
the two jedi teach ahsoka how to be the
best person jedi leader and soldier that
she can be she keeps those teachings
with her as she rebels against the
empire long after the clone wars come to
an end ahsoka comes to regard obi-wan
and anakin as one does their parents for
all intents and purposes they are her
parents
while obi-wan is patient humble and
forward-thinking anakin is impulsive
overconfident and eager to rush into
danger the fact that they come to
balance each other out is a large part
of what makes them such an incredible
team it's no surprise then that ahsoka a
student of both jedi comes to embody the
balance between them when she first
begins as anakin's padawan she is
arrogant and quick to jump the gun
because she's intelligent and competent
she's also often right which fuels her
recklessness eventually a series of
mistakes teaches her humility in this
sense she's quite similar to her master
by the time the clone wars finally end
she develops a patient strongly
reminiscent of obi-wan's this results in
the best of both worlds balance like
anakin ahsoka never hesitates to leap to
someone's aid but like obi-wan she knows
the value of slowing down to plan before
deciding her next move
you have one day
to decide
in season four's kidnapped anakin ahsoka
and obi-wan investigate the
disappearance of a colony of ahsoka
species called to grudas when they
arrive the trio discovered that the
entire colony has been taken by zigerian
slavers anakin is furious and though
it's obvious to ahsoka why her master
finds slavery abhorrent she doesn't
understand his personal stake in the
crime it's at this point the audience
realizes anakin has told ahsoka nothing
of his own history so when ahsoka asks
obi-wan about it after anakin leaves he
tells her about her master's childhood
in slavery it's a fascinating scene and
it illustrates the trio's relationship
well when anakin shuts her out ahsoka
goes to obi-wan who tells her what she
needs to know while still respecting
anakin's desire for privacy
in the final arc of the clone wars
season 5 ahsoka is put through one of
the worst experiences of her life she is
framed for bombing the jedi temple even
though she was in another part of the
galaxy when it happened many jedi do not
believe her and a warrant is placed for
her arrest forcing her to flee and
attempt to clear her name on her own
when the jedi finally catch her they
decide to put her on trial but at
supreme chancellor palpatine's request
the jedi agreed to have ahsoka face
court as a military officer and not a
jedi so ahsoka finds herself before a
republic military tribunal
in order for ahsoka to be judged by the
republic she must first be expelled from
the jedi order though obi-wan initially
tries to stand up for ahsoka he
ultimately relents and sides with the
rest of the council and so by a near
unanimous vote the jedi council casts
ahsoka out
when anakin finally clears her name
ahsoka is invited to rejoin the order
but the sting of this betrayal still
lingers and she refuses ahsoka loves and
trusts obi-wan but when she needs a most
he does not have her back
anakin and obi-wan don't discuss
ahsoka's departure from the jedi order
until season seven however a cancelled
story arc called crystal crisis on
udapal was originally set to address her
absence the ark is still considered
canon and the story reels of the
unfinished episodes were eventually
released on starwars.com
in the ark's second episode in search of
the crystal anakin mentions ahsoka for
the first time since the incident
prompting a discussion with obi-wan as
they set up camp for the night anakin
tells his master how much he misses his
former padawan and is obviously angry
that she left the order but when obi-wan
emphasizes that it was her decision to
leave anakin responds
well what choice did we give her anakin
blames the council for refusing to stand
by ahsoka in her time of need but
obi-wan disagrees he blames ahsoka
claiming her emotions affected her
decision since that's against the jedi
code it is thus her failure to act like
a jedi that caused her to leave he
effectively paints her leaving as some
sort of childish tantrum completely
disregarding the legitimacy of her
position
obi-wan kenobi seems like the definitive
jedi he's humble compassionate and
self-controlled but ahsoka comes to
believe that obi-wan embodies the jedi
order's flaws during the war the jedi
become dominated by politics and
transform from peacekeeping monks into
generals of one of the galaxy's largest
armies this ultimately blinds them to
the needs of the common man
when the jedi council exiles ahsoka they
do so because they don't want the senate
to think they've lost their impartiality
though there is wisdom in this they fail
to take any additional action to protect
ahsoka or discover what truly happened
instead they abandoned her which forces
her to rethink everything she once
believed about the order this comes to a
head in season seven's old friends not
forgotten when ahsoka asks her old
masters to help against maul on
mandalore they abandon her again to rush
to the battle of coruscant when she
challenges their decision obi-wan says
that coruscant's people need them but
ahsoka rightly states that they're going
only for the chancellor once again
they're playing politics instead of
helping people it's the jedi's duty to
serve everybody not just one man in
calling her old masters out ahsoka
illustrates something she says in season
three's the academy it's every citizen's
duty to challenge their leaders in e.k
johnston's novel star wars ahsoka
readers join ahsoka tano a year after
order 66 at this point the former jedi
is still alone and on the run from the
empire she hasn't yet joined any
rebellions or even started to process
all that she has lost but when a new
acquaintance asks about her past she
claims to be an orphan who was adopted
obviously she's hiding the truth of her
past as a jedi who was raised in the
jedi temple but throughout the exchange
she refers to anakin and obi-wan as her
adoptive parents and smiles fondly as
she remembers how they constantly
bickered quote like an old married
couple despite how strained and broken
their relationship has become by this
point ahsoka still chooses to remember
obi-wan with warmth and love she accepts
how important he is to her flaws and all
following the bloody rampage of order 66
ahsoka mourns obi-wan which is made all
the more tragic by the fact that obi-wan
isn't actually dead unbeknownst to
either character they both survive the
great jedi purge and go on to oppose the
empire in their own ways
only bill organa and yoda know that
obi-wan goes into hiding on the planet
tatooine to protect his former pupil son
luke ahsoka eventually joins forces with
bale organa and works closely with him
in forming the rebellion but he never
reveals obi-wan's fate the existence of
anakin's child is simply too important
to risk telling anybody even ahsoka
likewise obi-wan is purposefully out of
contact with the rest of the galaxy
which means nobody can tell him about
ahsoka when he leaves tatooine with luke
aboard the millennium falcon everyone
believes ahsoka is dead by the time
anyone knows that wasn't true obi-wan
has been killed by his own apprentice by
then known as the fearsome darth vader
check out some of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about star wars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]